pasado estábamos platicando como hay
múltiples formas de definir retornos
sobre los activos aquí a la izquierda
tenemos una definición que se da en
algunos libros de texto que algunos
profesores la dan en su clase de
finanzas y ese ingreso neto entre activo
en wikipedia tienen que ese ingreso neto
más interés menos el ahorro de impuestos
por el interés observa lo están
agregando todo el impuesto otra vez
simplemente están sumando los impuestos
pero están restando la deducción de
impuestos por el interés después vamos a
hablar de eso entonces estoy acá
considera tantito los impuestos están
acá definitivamente y también el interés
y también están estas dos que me
gustaban más una era con utilidad
operativa dividido entre activo que era
la que tiene el primer vídeo que pues
simplemente era una simplificación para
darte la intuición de que quería decir
roja o sea que tan buena es una compañía
manejando su activo
y bueno manejando los y obteniendo un
retorno y una definición de un poquito
más general sería dividido entre activo
y ya hablamos acerca de ebit verdad
simplemente es ingreso neto más interés
más impuestos o también podríamos
pensarlo como utilidad operativa más
utilidad no opera
es decir más aquella utilidad que la
compañía haya hecho a partir de activos
que tiene que no sean esenciales para
hacer las actividades empresariales pero
bueno en la última parte del vídeo dije
pues tienes estas definiciones pero no
me gusta usar estas dos verdad se me
acabó el tiempo dije que en este vídeo
daría un ejemplo para decir por qué no
me gustan tanto entonces pasamos al
ejemplo supongamos que tenemos dos
compañías dos compañías
déjame dibujarla por aquí compañía
déjame ponerle un poco más grueso con
una línea que se vea más entonces
supongamos que tenemos aquí una compañía
y que tienen la misma cantidad de
activos
ahora que está la otra compañía y estoy
intentando dibujar el lado izquierdo de
su hoja de balance entonces estoy acá es
el activo activo acá también es activo
y supongamos que tienen la misma
cantidad de activo va que ambas
compañías tienen la misma cantidad y que
es 10 millones en activo 10 millones y
supongamos que acá a la izquierda este
cuate supongamos que son las de aquí
arriba va eso de acá son los retornos
sobre activos como los cálculos o sea
esto de acá es el ebit dividido entre el
total de activo entonces si el ebit es
el 10% de esto esto quiere decir que
este cuate obtuvo un ebit de 10% o sea
de un millón un millón de pesos muy bien
de ebit ahora en un mundo donde no hay
utilidad no operativa esto lo podemos
pensar como la utilidad operativa
recuerda que el ebit simplemente es
ganancias antes de intereses e impuestos
verdad vamos acá arriba al estado de
resultados entonces ebit es ganancias
antes de intereses e impuestos entonces
si regresamos el interés y los impuestos
esencialmente regresamos a la utilidad
operativa a menos que haya un poquito de
utilidad no operativa entonces así
podemos pensar en el ebit para casi
todas las situaciones a menos que
tengamos algo así como una compañía
financiera para qué
todas las situaciones el ebit y la
utilidad operativa están muy muy cerca
entre sí en este caso este cuate está
generando un millón de pesos en ebit y
supongamos que esta compañía déjame
ponerle etiquetas a las compañías esta
es a y aquí ve para saber cuál es cuál
entonces la compañía de está obteniendo
15 por ciento de retorno sobre sus
activos cuando lo tomamos con el ebit
entonces está generando 1.5 millones en
edit
cada año entonces así simplemente al ver
el lado izquierdo de las hojas de
balance todavía no ha dibujado el lado
derecho yo diría que este monito ve sabe
administrar mejor su activo está sacando
más valor dada la cantidad de recursos
que tiene en su compañía entonces por
eso me gusta más la definición de ebit
dividida entre activo o bien utilidad
operativa dividida entre activos ahora
supongamos que a
bueno pensemos en la situación en la
cual a tiene muy poquita deuda vamos a
pensar que tiene no pensamos que no
tiene nada de deuda mejor
todo todo lo de la derecha es capital
entonces el lado derecho de la hoja de
balance se vería algo así supongamos que
no tiene ningún pasivo de importancia
esto de acá es pasivo
pasivo no perdón aquí es activación no
tiene pasivo y todo es todo es capital
eso dije verdad todo es capital entonces
cuando quieres determinar el ingreso
antes de impuestos de este cuate
entonces tomas el ebit y le restas estas
que déjame bajar un poquito entonces
tomas edith menos interés para obtener
el ingreso antes de impuestos y cuánto
tiene el ingreso antes de impuestos
entonces pues no tiene nada de deuda
verdad entonces no tiene que pagar nada
de interés entonces su ingreso antes de
impuestos o bueno puede llamarle efe
pero no quiere llamar ebit porque va a
sonar muy parecido a eb y todo el mundo
le llama ingresos antes de impuestos
para evitar esa confusión pero también
sería de un millón de pesos muy bien y
luego si quisieras proseguir con esto y
dice sabes que este cuate por alguna
razón tuvo un montón de deducciones de
impuestos de este año o tuvo pérdidas el
año pasado y pudo deducir las este año
entonces este año tampoco tuvo que pagar
nada de impuestos ok entonces sus
ganancias ya su ingreso neto
finalmente también sería de un millón de
pesos muy bien muy bien entonces este
cuate tiene un retorno edith de 10 por
ciento un retorno sobre activos de 10
por ciento pero sus ganancias verdad
también son de un millón de pesos ahora
vamos con el cual de acá supongamos que
éste tiene pues un poquito más de deuda
en su hoja de balance no sé algo similar
al primer ejemplo que hicimos entonces
no sé supongamos que tiene por decir
algo 5 millones de pesos en deuda déjame
escribirlo por aquí tengo la cantidad no
importa tanto vamos a ponerle 5 millones
en deuda o en pasivo podría haber otro
pasivo que no sea deuda verdad como
deudas como perdón cuentas por pagar o
algo así pero bueno entonces tiene 5
millones en deuda pero la parte
importante es que tiene que pagar
interés no sé digamos de 500 mil pesos
al año para entonces está pagando una
tasa de 10 por ciento una tasa de 10 por
ciento de 5.500.000 entonces su ingreso
antes de impuestos déjame escribir esto
debajo de su hoja de balance
entonces el ebit sus ganancias antes de
intereses e impuestos sería 1.5 millones
pero luego
el interés verdad hay que quitarle el
interés dijimos que es quinientos mil
pesos menos punto cinco millones de
pesos eso es lo mismo entonces su
ingreso antes de impuestos sería de 1.5
2.5 un millón de pesos si verdad jaja
ahora este cuate de acá bueno digamos o
sea que hay que poner el capital
entonces aquí tenemos 5 millones en
capital este 4 que tenía 10 millones en
capital estoy acá es el ingreso antes de
impuestos pero todavía tiene que pagar
impuestos entonces supongamos que por
ingresos sobre la renta se paga 30 por
ciento de modo que su ingreso neto
ingreso neto sería de 700 mil pesos
verdad tiene un millón tiene que pagar
300 mil en impuestos le quedan 700 mil
pesos de ingreso neto va ahora vamos a
ver cómo se ve esto en términos de roa
definido con este coeficiente de acá
utilizando esta definición quedan
algunos libros de texto
entonces el primer cuates un ingreso
neto fue de un millón de pesos y su
activo valía 10 millones entonces por la
definición de acá
verdad que es ingreso neto / activo la
compañía tiene 10% de retorno sobre los
activos por esa misma definición
aquí sería 700 mil pesos divididos entre
10 millones de este modo para ver la
compañía detendría según esta definición
un roa de 7% entonces pues si ves
superficialmente estos números definidos
por este coeficiente de acá podrías
decir que al parecer es mejor manejando
su activo es mejor obteniendo un retorno
por sus recursos pero eso es
completamente falso verdad la compañía
tenía un ebit mucho más pequeño y mucho
menos retorno sobre activos que éste de
acá que era de 15 por ciento la compañía
a simplemente era mejor bueno número uno
no tenía tanta deuda pero también digo a
lo mejor nada más este año pero era
mejor pagando impuestos entonces cuando
hablamos de roa hay algunas definiciones
que empiezan a considerar otro tipo de
habilidades de la compañía como qué tan
buena es financiando sus recursos
obteniendo una tasa de interés o también
qué tan buena es pagando sus impuestos o
reduciendo los digo está bien medir
estas cosas pero desde mi punto de vista
se tiene que hacer con otros
como yo lo veo es que retorno sobre
activo debe decir que está haciendo la
compañía con el lado izquierdo de su
hoja de balance cuando haces ingreso
neto interactivo estás metiendo otras
cosas como interés impuestos entonces
ensucias un poco el panorama no me estás
diciendo realmente cuál compañía es más
eficiente administrando su activo cuál
obtiene un mejor retorno sobre sus
recursos la definición que da wikipedia
y bueno es bueno estar al pendiente de
todas verdad o sea no quiero que digas
no pues sal dijo que su utilidad
operativa entre activo o bien evite
entre activo creo que es mejor conocer
todas pues para que te sean familiares
cuando te las mencionen más bien lo
importante es que esta definición o bien
esta otra son definiciones que nos dan o
más bien dejan una intuición de que está
haciendo una compañía con el lado
izquierdo de su hoja de balance esta de
acá la de wikipedia está añadiendo el
interés de regreso de modo que ese
coeficiente no detecta la diferencia de
la estructura de capital entre estas dos
compañías
entonces no detecta cómo están
financiados los activos de la compañía
pero eso sí si detecta cuál es buena o
cuál es mala pagando impuestos bueno me
acabo de dar cuenta que se me acabó el
tiempo así que en el siguiente vídeo voy
a platicar
un poco más a profundidad eso de los
ahorros en impuestos por financiar con
deuda aunque no sabes que creo que sería
meterse mucho en la maleza más bien
vamos a regresar a un nivel para ver las
cosas así desde arriba y vamos a
platicar un poco más de cómo pensar
acerca de las inversiones en el
siguiente vídeo nos vemos pronto